hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the video where I try not
to play what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
try not to play Minecraft because
there's nothing about my there's
definitely not like a demand for it yeah
I don't have to play there's nothing
good about it
oh wow Utah hope you tell us minecraft
you tell love digging so that makes
sense it's gonna be Colorado is you
can't be more popular that's not even
close
haha okay that's fine
wait Oh
porns wet okay porn horn wins first
second those a dip in porn usage due to
minecraft interested in porn Mississippi
Mississippi Utah killing it with the
Micra okay that's unfair okay
um how about that campy
[Music]
oh okay whatever it's it's fine it's
fine I won't do it I won't do it I won't
do it you can't make me do it you can't
I can't
I won't I'm not I don't fall to peer
pressure I don't I don't do it I don't
fall
[Music]